absolutely brutal heat is making Texas
one of the hottest places on Earth right
now and they have decided because
they're so big and strong that they
don't need to connect their electrical
grid to anybody else Texas is unique in
the contiguous United States in that it
cannot draw additional power needs from
neighboring states and we already saw
the disaster that this resulted in the
last few years we've seen during the
winter power outages and disasters in
Texas due to storms we've seen in the
summer power outages and disasters in
Texas due to the heat causing people to
run air conditioners overloading the
Grid at some point it would be a really
nice thing for someone to take charge in
Texas and say hey you know what some of
this nonsense we've been doing is simply
nonsense it's time to stop we're going
to actually do what's best for people
wouldn't that be a nice refreshing thing